[موسيقى]
الهجمات الكيماويه على مدارس البنات في
ايران جرسوا انذار للبحث في حل عاجل
لحمايه حق الفتيات في التعليم وتحقيق
المساواه بين الجنسين مجموعه بارزه من
النساء الافغانيات والايرانيات سياره حمله
تدعو الى الاعتراف بالفصل العنصري بين
الجنسين كجريمه بموجب القانون الدولي
الحمله التي انطلقت في اليوم العالمي
للمراه اكدت ان القوانين الحاليه التي
تعطي التمييز ضد المراه وتغطيه لا تعكس
الطبيعه السياسيه المنهجيه المفروضه في
افغانستان وايران لخفض مكانه المراه في
المجتمع ومن الموقعين على الرساله
المفتوحه شيرين عباد الايرانيه الحائزه
على جائزه نوبل للسلام وفوزيه في اول
نائبه لرئيسه البرلمان الافغاني وفق صحيفه
الجارديان يذكر مشاهدينا انه في حين ان
هنالك جريمه فصل عنصري في القانون الدولي
الا انها تنطبق فقط على المجموعات العرقيه
على الجنس
[موسيقى]
اتساع ورقعه الهجمات الكيماويه بمدارس
البنات في ايران دفع السلطات لسلوك
التجاعيد اولهما التشكيك بصحه الهجمات
وثاني اتهام الغرب بالوقوف ورائها اخر هذه
الاتهامات ساقها موقع اخباري ايراني يديره
الحرس الثوري للسفير البريطاني في طهران
بالتورط بشكل مباشر بموجه التسمم حيث شبه
موقع مشرق نيوز سياسه السفير البريطاني
بتعليمات نادي تشرشل دون تقديم دليل على
ادعاءاته علما بان نادي تشارتشيل هو
مجموعه من تلاميذ المدارس الدنماركيين
الذين ارتكبوا اعمال تخريب ضد الالمان
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه واضاف الموقع
ان مراجعته للانشطه حول المدارس اظهرت ان
جهاز المخابرات للعدو والشبكه المظلله
ينفذان هذا المشروع لاعاده اشعال اعمال
الشغف الشوارع التي خمدت وفق تعبيره